WESLEY CHUN: So this is
my co-worker Chris.
My name is Wesley Chun.
CHRIS SCHALK: Hello.
WESLEY CHUN: We're on Google's
Developer Relations team.
And we represent Google
Cloud Products.
App Engine is the first cloud
product that we have launched.
There will be plenty
more, coming soon.
CHRIS SCHALK: Can you guys
hear me OK as well?
Now that I got my mic on.
Thumbs up?
All right.
So shall we kick it off?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah, I just
did the intro already.
CHRIS SCHALK: Anyway, so as Wes
was saying, we work in the
Developer Relations.
I'm a developer advocate.
Wes is a developer programs
engineer.
We essentially do pretty much
very, very similar stuff.
We reach out to essentially
build developer ecosystems.
We help companies get on board
with Google technologies.
We focus specifically on
our cloud technologies.
So today, we're going to be
providing a general overview
of App Engine.
So granted, if you've worked
with App Engine before, some
of it might be stuff
you already know.
But there's definitely some
new stuff that we
want to talk about.
Also, I think we want to use
this talk as a plug for our
lab that we're doing later
today, as well.
And we definitely invite
you guys to come down.
We have some new content.
Actually, we created content
a while back.
But then for Google I/O, just
recently, we have some new
content that we'd like to have
you have some fun with.
So definitely App Engine.
Some fun stuff we'll be doing
in the lab today.
Anything else you want to say?
WESLEY CHUN: It's just
an extension to.
If you guys have done the online
tutorial, we find that
great to get started.
But it's kind of boring.
And so that's why we created
these code labs.
So it takes the existing online
tutorial, that lets you
build the Guest Book, and
we add more uses of
APIs on top of that.
And then, as Chris mentioned, we
added some new things, over
the last couple of weeks,
on top of that.
So there's actually three
parts to it all.
The Guest Book Tutorial, the
Guest Book Tutorial++, and
then this new material that
we're going to introduce to
you guys, for the first
time, this morning.
11:45 is the lab, if
you're curious.
So just bring your lunch,
because it takes place around
the lunch hour.
CHRIS SCHALK: So if you want to
play with like task queues,
URL fetch, cron jobs, deferred
task queues, actually, as well
as the Channel API, definitely
recommend you to check it out.
Channel APIs a really
cool technology.
I'll give you a demo of
it today as well.
Also we did have our feedback
QR code, so if you want to
give us live feedback
as we're talking.
And then we even have
another one for in
our lab session today.
And I'll have this slide
also at the end of the
presentation, so you can
take a quick shot of
it if you need to.
And then you can also
see the URL.
It's a little bit hard
to see, sorry.
But it should be OK.
All right, let's jump
right into it.
And we do go until
10:30, right?
WESLEY CHUN: 9:30 to 10:30.
CHRIS SCHALK: And feel
free to jump in.
I'm just going to give you guys
a bit of a high level,
landscape view of where Google
App Engine fits in.
So if you're familiar at all
with cloud technology, the
analysts have generally-- and
it's not just the analysts,
but the overall software
development community have
divided it up in the
three categories.
So at the top, you see software
as a service.
So these are the applications
that you guys are familiar
with, like Google Docs, and just
going online and using
productive cool technology,
entirely in the cloud.
WESLEY CHUN: In fact, you
have to have a web
browser to use these.
And that's the only way.
It's not like having an Outlook
application on your
desktop to check your email.
You're actually logging in and
checking your Gmail, your
Yahoo mail, or your Hotmail.
It's something that you
have to use online.
So that's software
as a service.
CHRIS SCHALK: And so
how do build the
software as a service?
Well, you can drop down a level
and actually have a
software development platform
as a service.
And that's where Google
App Engine fits in.
Now, I'll get into the
infrastructure as a
service in a second.
But App Engine, itself, is
referred to as a platform, in
the sense that it's an
entire development
platform in the cloud.
So you don't really have
to focus on lower level
infrastructure, setting up your
lower level servers and
stuff like that.
You just rely on the
platform itself.
And you focus entirely on the
application logic itself.
So you can see App Engine, it's
also got various other
peers in that realm of cloud
computing technology.
And then, of course, probably
most people are familiar with
the historical cloud
technology.
So if you've worked with
Amazon, EC2, Rackspace,
VMware, and so forth, those
give you a virtual
machine in the cloud.
And that's, pretty much, what
I would say, probably, the
majority of people, when they
were just getting started with
cloud technologies,
would be using.
We'd like to think that App
Engine is actually more
productive, in the sense that
you can actually just jump in,
create an app very quickly,
deploy it to the cloud, and
not worry about all the
infrastructure stuff.
WESLEY CHUN: So you can think
of infrastructure as, I'm
renting devices online.
I'm renting machines, VMs.
I'm renting disk, power,
cooling, Ethernet.
With the platform as a service,
you don't have to
worry about that.
You only have to worry
about your app.
And you don't need to think
about operating systems.
You don't need to think
about networking.
You just write the app.
And you upload it and host it.
CHRIS SCHALK: Want to take
this slide [INAUDIBLE]?
WESLEY CHUN: No, go ahead.
CHRIS SCHALK: So probably the
main point that we like to
stress is that App Engine,
it's easy to build.
You don't have to worry about
the infrastructure.
It's easy to maintain.
You have a cloud based
dashboard that
you can work with.
And, of course, most
importantly,
it's easy to scale.
You don't have to actually,
physically or even go through
a UI to start building up your
infrastructure in the cloud.
It can automatically grow
as your business grows.
So these are pretty much
the three main
points we like to stress.
WESLEY CHUN: Emphasize.
CHRIS SCHALK: So let's talk a
little bit about where App
Engine is today.
App Engine, as you may
know, launched
back in April of 2008.
WESLEY CHUN: It's
three years old.
CHRIS SCHALK: So we just passed
a three year birthday.
You may be surprised to see
some of these numbers.
We have a very large developer
audience, over 100,000 active
developers.
And that's not the total mass
of developers that go in and
sign in to build an app.
Actually, these guys are
actually working and having
traffic on their applications.
And as you can see, the
slope is not linear.
It's actually continuing
to go up.
200,000 active apps per week.
So obviously, we have thousands
of apps that are
doing multiple different
things.
Whether it's a front facing
web app, whether it's some
sort of web service, or some
sort of backend service to a
social or mobile app, they
come in all categories.
And so, as you can see here, we
just continue to grow, with
more and more applications.
WESLEY CHUN: The "hello world"
thing that you guys tried and
just let it sit forever, that's
not one of these.
CHRIS SCHALK: And we've actually
just surpassed 1.5
billion page views per day.
WESLEY CHUN: This is across all
apps, on a daily basis.
CHRIS SCHALK: So on a daily
basis, keep in mind.
It's not just [? once ?]
[? at a ?] time.
So who are these people building
all these apps?
Well, we have a very large
database of partners, users
that we interact with.
We even have a core set of
people that we literally talk
to almost every day.
So yes, we have thousands
of partners.
But we do have like a high level
set of people that we
interact quite a bit with.
So you may recognize
some of the names.
Some of them are more
traditional applications that
in are enterprise-y type
of applications.
Also, there's many applications
that are in the
gaming space.
And then, of course, social.
Social was one of the very
important audiences with
Google App Engine back when
it launched in 2008.
WESLEY CHUN: Well, the other
thing is, if you look at the
list there, you'll see big
names, like Best Buy and
Forbes and MTV.
But, of course, they don't run
their entire website off of
App Engine.
But they do run certain
components of their website on
App Engine.
CHRIS SCHALK: So I'd like to
point out one of our partners,
in particular.
And they'll actually be talking
at our session tomorrow.
WESLEY CHUN: And I think they
also have a Sandbox.
CHRIS SCHALK: That's right.
So WebFilings is one of App
Engine's most important
partners, in the sense that
they've done an awesome job by
building a SaaS application that
allows companies to file
their financial results
to the SEC.
The first time we invited them
over, they gave us a demo of
their application.
And we were all, this
is amazing.
Hats off to you guys.
And they've been able to take
their very rich, helpful
application and really
be successful
in Fortune 100 companies.
So if you go to their website,
you can just look at their
list of partners that they
are now signing on.
And their growth rate is very
similar to App Engine.
It's going by leaps
and bounds.
And so they've actually had
quite bit of success, in the
Fortune 100 companies.
So I think it's important to
notice that App Engine, it
came, maybe traditionally, from
grass roots developers,
social, gaming, but it's now
working itself into enterprise
adoption, essentially,
and having success.
WESLEY CHUN: So App Engine is
the maturing, from just a
developer tool or developer toy,
into something that real
companies do use for
real business.
You can imagine how fun
it is to create SEC
filings every quarter.
So these guys have come
up with a novel way--
CHRIS SCHALK: Probably the wrong
audience for that joke.
[INAUDIBLE]
WESLEY CHUN: Well, they found
a way to actually make that
more pleasant for
these companies.
So they're signing on
pretty quickly.
CHRIS SCHALK: So BuddyPoke,
this is one of
our historical partners.
They have numerous social apps
on both Facebook and all the
other social networks.
So this is like the traditional
core, original
types of the partners that
we've worked with.
And of course, gaming.
We have a number of folks out
there that are building
backends, frontends with
App Engine, in
numerous manners as well.
And then, you may have noticed,
a certain wedding a
little while ago.
Actually, if you had watched
the news, Google App Engine
actually provided the official
royal wedding website.
And so, as you can see, on the
wedding day, had up to 2000
requests per second, 15 million
page views, 5.6
million visitors So there's the
actual short link there.
But you can go, and you can
Google the royal wedding
website, and you'll be going to
an App Engine application.
Incidentally, one of our
engineers actually created the
blog application that
is running this.
So it's entirely a homegrown
solution, in that sense.
Let's jump into the App Engine
details, so a bit of the
technology.
So, obviously, if you work
with App Engine, you
understand the key components.
But if you're new, we like to
think of it as SDK in a box or
cloud development
SDK in a box.
So, first of all, you get
a downloadable SDK.
You download it onto
your machine.
That SDK has the
capabilities--
well, you can either download
the Python or the Java SDK.
And those are the two core
languages that we support.
And then, in order to build
your applications, you can
pick whatever tools or
use command lines
or what have you.
But we do offer, like on the
Java side, specific support
for Eclipse.
So our team has actually built
a plug-in specifically
designed for Eclipse.
We also have a third party IDE
plug-ins, like NetBeans,
IntelliJ, and so forth that are
built out there that you
can use as well.
Now, on the Python side, there's
also this nice utility
called the App Engine Launcher,
which allows you to
create, debug, check the logs,
and also deploy your
application on the Python
side, as well.
Now, these are tools that
augment what you can already
do command line as well.
And then, of course, the whole
magic of the App Engine is
you've got all these great
services that you can use.
So you go through the
documentation, you can use
high speed memory caching,
memcache.
You can use the backend
datastore, which is based off
of a Google's Big Table.
And we're continuously updating
these new services.
And they're all made available
for you, immediately, as you
build you apps.
So you don't have to go
through-- like on the Java
side, go out and fetch JAR files
and rig your application
in a kind of Frankenstein
manner.
All this content is there, ready
to go, for a wide array
of services.
And, of course, the other very
important point is that, once
you build your application,
you can test
it, debug it locally.
You even have a mini dashboard
to check the various elements
of your application.
And then once you deploy it,
you have a dashboard in the
cloud, where you go through and
check the logs, check the
overall health, see what kind of
warnings, errors, so forth
that's come up.
And, of course, check the
overall traffic, once you get
into an operational mode.
And that application in the
cloud, you can also manage the
financial aspects, manage
the growth of the
application in general.
Anything else?
These specialized services,
I touched on just a few.
But, as you can see, memcache,
high speed memory, datastore,
URL fetch, task queues.
So, literally, a very rich
palate by which you can build
your applications,
from the get go.
So you build your app and
just immediately use
some of these services.
And we have a lot of
documentation out there that
allows you to jump in and just
get busy programming.
We'll show you some of that
stuff today [INAUDIBLE].
WESLEY CHUN: So one of the
reasons why we give you all
these services is, you need to
understand, whenever you're
writing an app in the cloud,
you're actually sharing all
these resources with other
cloud developers as well.
And we certainly don't want you
to be able to break into
other people's apps and be able
to steal their data and
vice versa.
We want to keep all
your stuff safe.
So what that means
is that your app
needs to run in a sandbox.
A controlled environment
by which you
can't do certain things.
So it doesn't help violate
security and things like that.
So things you can't do are like,
you can't create a local
file, you can't make a system
call, you can't open a socket
connection.
So those things sound
kind of restrictive.
Because, if I told that to begin
with, you'd say, well
what the heck kind of app
am I going to write?
If I can't even open a socket,
it's not going
to be really useful.
So you have to ask yourself the
question, why would you
want to open a socket?
Maybe you want to send email
or even receive email.
Or maybe you want to talk to
another app that's online.
So that's what why we provide
these higher level APIs to
proxy for that missing
functionality.
And, of course, if there's
something missing, feel free
to give feedback to the team.
And based on how popular that
demand is for that feature,
we'll try our best to
get the product team
to implement that.
So that's the reason why
we provide all these.
It's not just a sales pitch,
like, oh, we got this API,
we've got this API.
These things serve a purpose.
And that is to get around
the sandbox.
Or not actually get around
it, it's a substitute for
something you can't do, because
of the execution
environment that you're in.
Does that make sense
to everybody?
CHRIS SCHALK: And it all boils
down to scalability.
And so there's reasons why some
of those things are a
little bit more restrictive,
but they're meant so your
application--
and it's also good for you--
can actually scale to
thousands, just, literally,
global traffic, entirely.
So let's talk about our
language runtimes.
As you know, we have Python
support and Java.
So these are both a
built-in, native
support within App Engine.
We actually build out the
interfaces on both sides, and
we keep them both, essentially,
on par with
[INAUDIBLE].
Sometimes, maybe, there might
be a new feature that comes
out in Python, but then Java
will then catch up.
And then vice versa, there might
be a new feature for a
temporary time, and then the
Python one catches up.
But it's very nice, though.
Because like, for us, who
actually balance on both
sides, it's nice to see the
parallel support that our
teams are putting together.
And it keeps the knowledge
still the same.
So the core concepts are still
the same, across the board.
So if you understand App Engine
on the Java side, it's
really not a big stress to jump
over on the Python side.
WESLEY CHUN: But the vice versa
is probably not true.
CHRIS SCHALK: Little bit, might
be a little harder.
WESLEY CHUN: I'm not
balanced at all.
I'm unbalanced.
So I'm mostly all Python.
And I don't know
too much Java.
And every time I look at
Java it scares me.
But I can see how
it so popular.
CHRIS SCHALK: It
scares me too.
So as you can see, on the Java
side, we do provide the
familiar interfaces.
So this basically allows any
typical or standard Java EE
developer to go ahead and
use the same patterns,
methodologies that they
are familiar with.
So using servlets.
If they want to use JB
or JPI, they can.
We also do have a low level API,
across the board, where
you can jump in directly and
just use those APIs.
And we actually have the boot
camp lab, Ikai is running.
What time is it?
WESLEY CHUN: It's later
this afternoon.
It's like 1:45 or 4 o'clock.
I think he's running
two sessions.
So if you are already a an
existing App Engine developer,
and you're still having problems
totally wrapping your
head around the datastore,
he's got some really good
exercises for you to just jump
in and get knee deep into it.
CHRIS SCHALK: Yeah, definitely
recommend it.
Basically, the bottom line here
is that Java developers
can feel comfortable using
familiar interfaces.
But they can drop down even
to the lower interfaces.
Sometimes you might actually see
some slight improvements.
Like the datastore API is
actually a little bit better
on the low level API level.
So, because Java support has
essentially a virtual machine
running behind it, that
allows you to
even have other languages.
So you can write your
applications in Ruby, Ruby
PHP, JavaScript, Python,
and really any other.
Actually, I gave a talk, about
two months ago, at a CFML
developers conference,
believe it or not--
cold fusion markup language.
Because there's actually a
Java runtime that will
essentially execute CFML.
There's like this community of
open source CFML developers
that are building nonprofit
websites with their--
WESLEY CHUN: There are people
using cold fusion?
CHRIS SCHALK: Yes.
WESLEY CHUN: Oh.
CHRIS SCHALK: I used it
too, back in the day.
WESLEY CHUN: So one thing about
the PHP is that people
think, oh, this is
full PHP support.
Not quite.
Because App Engine runs on a
non-relational datastore, you
can't exactly embed SQL
inside your PHP code.
You still have to talk
to JDO and JPA.
So your PHP is going to
be a little tweaked.
It doesn't perform as badly
as you may think.
It actually performs
quite well.
However, you still have to kind
of change your way of
writing your PHP code,
if you do want to
choose and use that.
The last one you might
think is kind of odd.
Why would I want to write Python
and run it top of a JVM
when I can use the native
Python library?
And one of the main reasons
for that is you could have
spent the last 6, 7, 10 years
building out all of your Java
classes and infrastructure, and
you really don't want to
port everything over.
But you do want to take
advantage of Python rapid
development.
So using Jython, you can
actually instantiate Python
classes as well as Java
classes, and they
talk to each other.
So that's one of the reasons
why you consider Jython.
CHRIS SCHALK: So let's talk
about the platform.
Hope you like the shoe.
WESLEY CHUN: He spent
a lot of time on it.
CHRIS SCHALK: Yeah, I did.
Actually, truth be told, I had
another slide that was an oil
platform, but it just
didn't work.
And so hence the.
I'm proud of my little
creation there.
And Wes liked it too,
so we kept it in.
WESLEY CHUN: At 2:00 in the
morning, I liked anything.
CHRIS SCHALK: That's right.
Let's talk about the platform
in general.
Oh, you want to take a picture?
Go ahead.
All my hard work on Photoshop.
WESLEY CHUN: You're just
feeding his ego.
CHRIS SCHALK: Easy.
Let's talk about the platform.
So first of all, as I mentioned,
you got the SDK.
You can build it, debug your
application locally, and then
you deploy it to the cloud.
And this is where
you get a really
cool App Engine dashboard.
And so I'll show you
how it works.
But basically, you get all of
the important information, all
the management stuff at your
fingertips, all in the cloud.
WESLEY CHUN: Oh, come on.
That's the sales side again.
Why are we really doing this?
Again, you're executing
in a sandbox.
It's a restricted environment.
Oh, I don't have access
to my logs.
I can't dig.
I can't write my own
metrics tool.
I can't re-write a
reporting tool.
Those things are bad.
I mean, you're not used to
that, if you're doing
traditional hosting.
So if you're going to host with
us, we need to give you
something that you would
find useful to kind
of make up for that.
And that's what the
Admin Console is.
And actually, this diagram
is about two years old,
believe it or not.
It does tell you a lot
of things still.
It shows you how much
usage you have.
How close you are to the
end of your quota.
How much it's costing you.
All this kind of stuff.
But since then, we've actually
added a lot more features to
the Administration Console.
But that's just a snapshot view
of what are some of the
numbers that you do get, to show
you the kind of traffic
you're getting, what
your errors are,
and things like that.
CHRIS SCHALK: We also provide
a general system health
webpage as well.
And so if you want to just check
up on any of the various
services, you can go to the this
overall App Engine system
health webpage.
And it also provides a
historical look as well.
WESLEY CHUN: Just keep in mind
that this is for all apps in
the entire system.
So if your app is running into
any kind of difficulty, maybe
the other 199,000
apps are not.
So you'll still see
green check marks.
And then you're going to be
mad, because it doesn't
reflect your particular
situation.
So just keep in mind that this
is a global, overall system
type of thing and
not necessarily
just tied to yours.
And depending on the various
thresholds that we have, these
things can go from the green
check-mark to one of the more
warning ones and then go
back within an hour.
You don't really know what's
going to happen.
So don't rely on this completely
to help you manage
and monitor your app.
But it is an overall system
view, to give you an idea of
how well the whole thing
is behaving overall.
CHRIS SCHALK: So let's talk
about the tools, the
developmental tools for App
Engine that you get.
So as I mentioned before,
for Python developers--
and of course, you can work
in command line mode.
You can develop entirely,
without even touching a
developmental tool.
But for Python, we do provide
a simple utility.
It's not like, obviously,
an entire IDE.
But if you want to quickly
create a brand new template
app that gets you started,
go through and, as you're
debugging, look at the logs.
And then of course, when you're
ready to deploy, it
offers, essentially, a simple
deployment utility
that plugs you in.
So a simple time saving type
of utility, essentially.
Now, I should also say that,
as you're debugging your
application locally, we actually
do provide a local
SDK console.
So this comes in handy, if
you're working, say, on
Python, and you want to check
your cron jobs, your task
queues and see them actually
running locally,
you can do all that.
And of course, most importantly,
if you're using
the datastore to check your
data, you actually go in, see
the data, and you can update it,
literally, if you need to.
Now on the Eclipse side, for
you Java developers, we do
provide a very helpful tool.
And similar to the App Engine
launch utility on the Python
side, it does the core things.
Allows you to create a very
simple starting application
and, of course, deployment
as well.
But I think, probably, the most
value add, in this case,
is that you're using Eclipse
IDE, which is,
obviously, very popular.
You get debugging support.
You get, essentially, a very
familiar Java development
environment.
And this is what Google
provides.
There's also, as I mentioned
before, third party tools, IDE
plug-ins for NetBeans, IntelliJ,
and so forth.
And so you can use
those as well.
I should also say, if there's
any Google Web Toolkit
developers out there, there is a
certain level of integration
support within the plug-in.
So it's actually meant for
both Google Web Toolkit
developers as well as App
Engine developers.
And you can decide, if you want,
to create say, like an
initial starter application
using both technologies
together or just App
Engine by itself.
Now for our labs that we're
going to be doing later today,
we're going to be focusing
purely on App Engine.
But I think there's other stuff
that they're going to be
covering both of
them together.
So definitely recommend checking
those out as well.
So let's go ahead and
just do some simple
work with App Engine.
So this is Eclipse.
So I'll do like a real
simple Java stuff.
And if you want to play around
on the Python, maybe.
Or I can just fire up the App
Engine launcher to do
something really simple.
But just to get started, I can
do a File, New Project.
And then I can select, Web
Application Project.
Now, of course, I could also
just click on this little
handy button here, which is what
I'll do right there, New
Web Application Project.
And I'll call it Hello
BootCamp or
I'll call it I/O BootCamp.
There we go.
And I'll give it a
simple package.
So this is, essentially, what
you can do after you've
downloaded the SDK, and you've
set up your Eclipse
environment, so you're ready to
essentially start building
applications.
Now, I can actually build and
run an application, even
before I've even registered
a brand new, in the cloud,
placeholder.
So I'll show you that
process in a second.
But let me just start with
something really quickly.
Now, this is that I thing that
I was talking about.
For now, I'll leave this off.
If I turn that on, that will add
additional example code on
how to work and build a Google
Web Toolkit application
running on App Engine.
So I'll hit Finish.
It'll create my simple
project.
And it really is a very simple
project, just so
you can have a look.
All it really does is set up,
with a very simple servlet
that responds to a get request
and says, hello world.
But this is a very helpful
application, in the sense that
you can then, very quickly,
augment what is here and add
more services as you
continue it on.
Now, of course, I could hit the
Run button and just run it
and see it in a browser.
But to give you a feel for the
value add that you get with an
integrated development
environment like Eclipse, I'll
just go ahead and hit the
Debug button there.
And that fires up the web
application in debug mode.
I'll open up the browser.
So I have a welcome file.
Actually, the application
generates a simple index.html,
which is a welcome file.
This has a link to the actual
servlet that I pointed to.
As I click on it, I'm actually
now doing the get request to
the associated servlet, which
is now responding with the
hello world message.
So I'll click on the
Run button, again.
Because I've now paused
the execution.
So for those of you who are
not familiar with Eclipse,
bear with us.
But basically, it's basic
Eclipse debugging.
And if I go back to the browser
window, I can now see,
basically, hello world,
right there.
So that's a very simple demo of
how to get started with an
application.
What I can do now is--
let me switch my perspective
back to Java perspective.
Now, if I wanted to then go
out and create a brand new
application, I would
log into my
cloud application dashboard.
So in this sense, I've
logged into my
external Gmail account.
I can go ahead and create
an application.
So I can say, I/O BootCamp.
I'll just put my name on it.
So this is a new application
that I'll be
creating on the fly.
Let's just go ahead
and create it.
I can use that later
on today, anyway.
So now that I've created my
application, I can go to the
dashboard and look at
the application.
I can see, obviously, there's
no traffic on it yet.
Now, I'm going to take this
application ID or an
application title, this is the--
or actually, right here,
is probably more correct--
this is the thing that links
my application that I built
locally to the cloud version
of this app.
Now, as you recall, this
is still empty.
It's a placeholder right now.
So I'll go back to
this application.
And I can Edit my App Engine
dash web.xml and add the
application there.
Or I can just do a quick click
and go to Properties.
And then I'll click
on App Engine.
As you can see, I got a little
spot there to add my
application ID.
So I'll place that there.
And at this point,
we're good to go.
We can actually click on the
little Deploy button.
Or I do right click
and Deploy To.
But I'll just click on
it very quickly.
I'm going to hit on
the Deploy button.
It's then preparing my
application, getting it ready
for upload.
And then it's now deploying the
application in the cloud.
So sometimes on longer or larger
applications, it might
take a little while.
But typically, it's anywhere
between a minute or 15
seconds, depending.
So I'll give that
a few seconds.
And then the other thing that
I'll do is prep up my first
access of this application.
And I'll just query it.
So there it is.
It's now live.
And I'll click on the
little link there.
And there it is.
So I actually built an
application from scratch and
deployed it to the cloud within
just, I don't know, a
few minutes or so.
So, anyway--
let me switch back to
our presentation.
Python side, do you want to
do a little simple stuff.
I can fire up the App Engine
launcher, and we can do a very
simple application creation here
on this side if you like?
WESLEY CHUN: Sure.
CHRIS SCHALK: So let's see.
I/O BootCamp.
So I'll just give it a
real simple hello.
WESLEY CHUN: That simple?
CHRIS SCHALK: I/O
BootCamp Hello.
I think I'll put this in
my Python App Engine.
WESLEY CHUN: I'm just teasing.
CHRIS SCHALK: So anyway, so
I created a very simple
application.
I can click on the Run button.
That fires it up.
And then also what I'll do
is pop open the Finder.
And I think actually created
it right here.
There it is.
So these are the main files
that you get started with.
The main dot PY file.
I'll just pop that
open in TextMate.
So in the similar fashion that
we had our servlet responding
to hello world, it's just
a simple Python handler.
Wes can definitely jump, since
he's the Python expert here.
WESLEY CHUN: No, no, no,
you can go ahead.
Actually, change the name of
your app to the one you have
uploaded, and then you
can upload this one.
CHRIS SCHALK: Oh, yeah,
that's a good one.
So here, I'm going to change
this to that, hit Save.
I'll go back to my utility
and hit Deploy.
It's got all that saved.
And it's firing off
the deployment.
Oh, I should have changed
the hello.
Oh well.
We can do it again.
But you get the idea.
So I'm now deploying the Python
version onto my cloud.
And also, I should return back
to the cloud dashboard, which
is now different.
Because now I actually
have an application.
Obviously, not much going
on here log-wise.
I can you put in a [? fave ?]
icon, [? ICO ?]
or whatever, and so forth.
And of course, since I'm not
working with data just yet, my
datastore viewer is not
showing anything.
I don't have cron jobs and
task queues and so forth.
But once I got an actually full
functioning app, I would
actually be able to step into
all that stuff very easily.
So it deployed and just for fun,
I can go out and do the
same thing.
Let's see, boom dot
appspot dot com.
Since I zoomed in.
Sorry, I got to refresh.
The other one was still.
There we go.
So that one doesn't
have that index--
WESLEY CHUN: So you can see he
actually did switch from the
Java to the Python app.
CHRIS SCHALK: Anyway, I can
jump back into our slides.
And that was just the getting
started stuff.
Apologies, if you guys are
already App Engine experts,
but definitely for people who
are new to it, it kind of
gives you an idea of
how to get started.
WESLEY CHUN: Notice which
one was faster.
CHRIS SCHALK: I showed
debugging-- oh, well.
I won't argue that one.
So let's take a look at all
these services and just
provide historical viewpoint
about of App Engine.
WESLEY CHUN: There will
be a quiz afterwards.
CHRIS SCHALK: That's right.
It's three years old.
We launched it in 2008.
Back when it was launched,
it was very simple.
It had Python support.
And then as time progressed,
we started adding on
additional features.
Memcache came not too long,
better logging support.
And then, of course, a very
important event happened in
2009, that's the Java launch.
That was a big deal.
WESLEY CHUN: I thought
it was FORTRAN.
CHRIS SCHALK: Well, that's
coming next.
WESLEY CHUN: Anybody remember
the FORTRAN launch?
Yeah, see.
CHRIS SCHALK: People didn't--
I don't know.
So the Java launch came out.
That opened up App Engine to a
whole new set of developers.
Some key things along the
way, task queues, XMPP
for building chatbots.
Which is actually part
of our lab that
we're doing later today.
You can build your own
chatbot with XMPP.
Blobstore, for just any kind of
blob storage, in the cloud.
That was a very important
feature, came out end of 2009.
Datastore cursors.
We announced App Engine for
business back last May.
Multi-tenancy, high performance
image surfing.
So obviously I'm not going
to read every feature.
But the main point here is that,
as you can see, over
time, we continuously add new
features and services.
And so, in that sense, what the
App Engine is today is not
going to be the App Engine of
say, six months from now or a
year from now.
It's just going to be continued
set of features that
you can take advantage
of down the road.
Also, I should say, very
importantly, we launched a
hybrid application datastore
and, of course, Channel API.
But hybrid application datastore
is actually a very
important feature.
It's a strategically important
feature to App Engine, in the
sense that it's a new and more
tolerant data storage
technology that is immune from
data latency spikes, that
sometimes have occurred
in the past.
So we definitely recommend
people using this new
technology.
We're getting--
most of our key partners are now
switched over, and they're
getting great results.
Like WebFilings, for example,
they have awesome results with
the hybrid application datastore
and so forth.
So they're quite
happy with it.
And then also, just in general,
as you can see, the
overall growth and continuous
growth of all the applications
has resulted, obviously, in
continuous interest from the
overall large population.
And, of course, looking to the
future, we have continuous
features with full MapReduce,
full-text search.
A new feature that we're
introducing, actually,
tomorrow, literally.
This idea of background servers,
so you can have long
running background services
that just
continue to do their thing.
They're like daemons, I guess,
is a good way to call it.
As you can see, continuously
adding,
augmenting more features.
So, anyway, shall we jump in?
I want to show them, also, the
sample application that we'll
be doing in the BootCamp
lab today.
Actually, I'll just give
you a demo real
quickly of how it works.
And then I'll show you a little
bit of how it was
built, as a sneak preview of
how you can actually step
through and build it yourself.
So first of all, before I jump
to the application, let me
just tell you what it does.
It uses the Channel API.
Actually, I'll step earlier.
It actually uses URL fetch to
go out and fetch news feeds.
And it pulls them down into
the local datastore.
And it keeps a registry
of fresh news feeds.
And then a person can just point
their browser to a URL.
And then, once they've
connected, the news feeds are
then streamed down to
the browser every
three seconds or so.
And so what that means is, it's
able to use like a comet
push, using the Channel API,
down to any client browsers
that have connected
to this website.
So in that sense, it's a
really cool feature.
You can have very rich,
interactive webpages.
So, in our example that we'll
do in the BootCamp today is
very simple.
It's just grabbing an XML feed
and stuffing it down into a
client browser.
But you could do any
number of things.
The data is data.
So you send down whatever
you want.
And then use whatever
visualization you want to,
whether it's some type
of visual graphs
and things like that.
You're totally welcome
to do that.
What we're doing in the BootCamp
is very simple.
We just grab some JSON, dump
it into a [? DIV ?] and it
gets updated very simply.
So that's the application
in a nutshell.
We have both versions,
a Java and a Python.
And if you come to the BootCamp,
you'll be be able to
actually build that within
the lab itself.
So let's go ahead and just
go to a version here.
News channel dash and then my
email, CShalk at [INAUDIBLE]
dot com.
And you notice, I have
a pop up here.
What this means is that, as I
viewed the page, as it loaded,
it actually created a connection
to the server.
And I clicked OK.
And then the only other
thing I need to do.
So now I have a socket
connection to the server, of
this demo application.
I can then go to the
same application--
I just had it a second ago.
There we go.
And kick off a set of tasks.
These are known as deferred
tasks, which will then execute
and queue up, essentially, a
set of jobs that will go
through and start pushing
out updates
to any client browsers.
So, as you can also see, I can
pop open a new window, make a
connection, and I should
also see the same
updates in the same way.
So anyway, just something fun
put together for the BootCamp
lab that you're definitely
welcome to build, either in
the lab itself or even, also,
take home as an exercise and
continue to augment.
Anything else you wanted
to touch on that?
WESLEY CHUN: No, that's good.
CHRIS SCHALK: Let's step back
over to our slides here.
And, of course, before we wrap
up, just also wanted to
provide you with where the info
is that you can learn
about App Engine if you're
just getting started.
So code.google.com/AppEngine is,
of course, the very first
place you'll want to
go check it out.
And, actually, that's pretty
much the home base.
We also provide the blog.
The blog is very important, if
you want to stay up to date
with any latest information,
obviously.
Whenever we launch new APIs and
services, we always get a
blog post out, so you can
start trying it out.
And, of course, you can use your
Google account to create
your own App Engine account,
essentially, turn it on.
So as typical Google fashion, as
long as you have a Gmail or
whatever, you get started.
And you can actually open it up
and turn on your App Engine
account within minutes.
And then be able to start
building applications and
literally deploying
them to the cloud.
Anything else you've been
wanting to mention before we
switch into Q&A mode?
WESLEY CHUN: So I think for the
blog, the blog is actually
interesting.
Because in addition to content
provided by us, employees, we
also, from time to time, invite
our external developers
and partners to also write blog
posts about interesting
products and tools that they're
building on App Engine.
CHRIS SCHALK: I'll just
give you a quick
test run through here.
So as you can see, there's
code.google.com/appengine.
I'll jump into the blog.
And I'll head back over to
the docs really quickly.
You may recognize this
particular blog post we just
did, recently, which talks about
how App Engine was used
for the official royal
wedding blog.
And if I continue to scroll
down, there's just a whole
bunch of technical information
that's constantly coming out,
on how you can essentially learn
what's the latest that's
going on with App Engine.
We had a WebFilings blog that
explained how they were using
the hybrid application
datastore, and it actually
worked out to their advantage
and allowed them to--
here it is, right here--
actually sign on some new
Fortune 100 companies.
They are quite happy
with it now.
Let me switch back to
the docs, just so
you get a basic idea.
So obviously our developers
guide caters to both the
Python and Java audience.
So we have some nice getting
started tutorials.
This getting started with Java
or Python is similar to the
initial set of the BootCamp
labs that we're doing.
But it's also kind of
more simplistic.
We actually extend upon these
getting started labs just for
a little bit more fun.
So we get into email,
XMPP, and so forth
on the basic stuff.
I'll switch back to the--
also, very importantly.
Since App Engine itself is
available open source, we have
the project externally.
And you can also log issues.
So if you want to see a
particular feature, you can
log it in our issue tracker,
and the team regularly goes
through the issues and
assigns priorities.
Also you can vote up features,
if you want.
We actually have people
want to see
native PHP support still.
So we're continuously
looking into that.
Obviously, that's a major
engineering effort to do that.
But yeah, we're definitely
looking at it.
Now, I should also
say, community.
And this is something
that Wes might even
want to chime in here.
As you can see, we have even
responses coming in from Wes.
We basically rely, for overall
support, we rely on the
overall App Engine community.
Plus we have people, Google
engineers, that are monitoring
constantly and checking to see,
essentially, what are
people's issues that pop up.
And Wes will just jump in and
help people out on the fly, on
certain technical issues.
I think with that--
WESLEY CHUN: The forums
have gurus too.
And gurus are basically very
experienced App Engine users
that are not Google employees.
So they're actually people
that make their living
building App Engine
apps every day.
And they contribute
on the forums.
Sometimes it's better to get
another voice that doesn't
belong to Google.
And that's why we have these
ambassadors of our forums.
And a couple will be here at
BootCamp as well as at I/O. So
feel free to say hi to them.
You'll find their names
if you go to the
forum, the About page.
CHRIS SCHALK: So I think with
wrapping up, we'd just like a
plug for our App Engine lab,
which is coming up at 11:45.
That's pretty soon.
I was thinking it was
a little bit later.
WESLEY CHUN: You were just
hoping it was going to be a
little later.
CHRIS SCHALK: So definitely, you
can bring your lunch and
come join us.
And we'll be able to step
through, not only like the
Channel API, more
advanced stuff.
But just even if you're getting
started, we'll be more
than happy to help you
get it started.
So at this point, I think
we can open it
up, if we have any--
WESLEY CHUN: Actually, before
we get into Q&A, one more
thing I wanted to
say about apps.
Because a lot of people come
and actually ask us this.
They go well, it's great.
You have this web tool.
It's a great execution
platform.
But what if I don't want
to build a web app?
Can I build an app that's
not user facing?
And the answer is
absolutely yes.
We actually have another class
of apps, where people are
building mobile applications,
where the frontend, that's
user facing, is actually
on a phone.
But they need some sort of
backend system, to maybe hold
high scores or leveling
or medals or whatever.
So with App Engine, all you
really need is to be able to
post something to us, from the
phone app, and we can,
effectively, help you with that
app, to give it a more
rich experience.
So for example, users can check
their high scores on a
website instead of just
on their mobile phone.
Or if, for some reason, they
lost their phone or dropped it
in the toilet or something.
When they get a new phone, they
don't want to have to
redo everything from scratch.
So if you store all these things
with a backend system,
like in App Engine, then you can
provide your users a much
more rich experience.
So the answer to that question
is, no, it doesn't have to
always be user facing.
It doesn't have to
be a web app.
It's just you can have any kind
of frontend, but you can
use App Engine as
your backend.
Because of the same reasons why
we described why you would
want to build a web app,
because you want that
scalability.
You want to be able to take
advantage of all of the
infrastructure the Google has
spent many, many years
building out, to make
our apps scalable.
So you guys can actually
get that to take
advantage of that.
So yes, so that's just one of
the last use cases I wanted to
mention before we get to Q&A.
CHRIS SCHALK: I was just putting
up the QR code here
really quickly.
Sorry, I was just going
to fix that.
WESLEY CHUN: Yes, question?
AUDIENCE: App store
[INAUDIBLE]
WESLEY CHUN: Have to is
a different word.
They automatically get one.
AUDIENCE: So what if
you are [INAUDIBLE]
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah, you can just
create a [? C name ?]
to it.
CHRIS SCHALK: And we did put
our Twitter handles here.
So we're going to try to keep
any helpful information, so
you're welcome to follow either
Wes or me or both of us
for any updates on Twitter.
WESLEY CHUN: Oh, the
App Engine one.
You should put the App Engine
one up there too.
It's at App underscore Engine.
You don't have to do it now.
Well, just do it now, then.
CHRIS SCHALK: Now that
we started it.
Here we go.
WESLEY CHUN: Underscore,
App underscore.
No, no, no, engine, no
app, just engine.
There you go.
And that's maintained by our
entire team, except Chris.
CHRIS SCHALK: Apparently.
WESLEY CHUN: Anybody
have questions
that we can't answer?
CHRIS SCHALK: I was going
to say, also--
WESLEY CHUN: It's all
confidential.
We can't tell you.
CHRIS SCHALK: I was
going to say, a
recommendation for this afternoon.
Please, if you're new to App
Engine, and you want to come
to the BootCamp lab, please
check the website for the
prerequisites.
WESLEY CHUN: Make sure
you have everything
downloaded and installed.
Because we don't want to spend
the first half of the lab
doing installation.
CHRIS SCHALK: Because on the
Java side, you definitely want
to make sure you got your JDK,
you got the Eclipse set up
before you actually
attend the lab.
It'll save you time.
You'll have much more enjoyable
experience at the
BootCamp lab.
Same thing for Python, just make
sure you're good to go.
It's typically lesson steps
for getting started.
WESLEY CHUN: Really?
CHRIS SCHALK: Any other
final questions as we
start to wrap up?
WESLEY CHUN: Question?
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS SCHALK: You can.
WESLEY CHUN: You can.
There's a plug-in called PyDev,
P-Y-D-E-V. That's the
most popular one.
I think there's two others, but
that's the one that most
people use, if you're
developing
Python using Eclipse.
Python has many other
IDEs as well.
But if you want to stay within
Eclipse, it's easier
to do it that way.
CHRIS SCHALK: We got a
question back there.
WESLEY CHUN: Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS SCHALK: So the question
is, can you install the
Android plug-in, in addition
to the Eclipse
plug-in for App Engine?
As far as I know,
I believe so.
I've had it on my system.
On my current system right
now, it's different.
But we're getting
confirmation.
WESLEY CHUN: There's a lot of
people saying, yes, up here.
CHRIS SCHALK: So I would
say, go for it.
I think it's fine.
I think as people are starting
to get ready for the next
session, we should probably go
ahead and get ready to--
a few more questions?
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WESLEY CHUN: Just post?
Post and get.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
WESLEY CHUN: There's
no API, right.
CHRIS SCHALK: So the question
was, basically, Android and
App Engine interactivity.
So, essentially, you
can use HTTP to get
posts and so forth.
And there's no problem with
that in that sense.
WESLEY CHUN: If you go back into
the blog and look like,
in August, there's an example.
A post that was made by myself
and another Android developer
that talks about their
experiences building a backend
on App Engine for their
Android app.
CHRIS SCHALK: So anyway, I just
wanted to thank you guys.
Welcome.
Thanks.
WESLEY CHUN: Thank you.
Have a great BootCamp.
CHRIS SCHALK: And good
luck with App Engine.